sanctuary Rayo is a great question for
the future governor our sanctuary cities
real or overblown GOP fear-mongering
completely overblown GOP fear mongering
it's just a fact and they don't look at
the facts they don't actually look at
the ordinance but it's complete it's
it's hyperbolic misinformation and it's
very difficult to get into the weeds
because no to sanctuary cities are alike
they're close to 300 now how would you
define it for people who haven't even
follow so I define it the way Rudy
Giuliani who was a big proponent of
sanctuary cities is that going to find
it in New York as almost every major
city mayor is Republican and Democrat
the bottom line is you want folks in
your city regardless of how they got
there regardless of their status to
cooperate with law enforcement if
someone is raped if someone is in a
domestic abuse situation you want them
to cooperate with police but if you're
concerned about someone on a family
being deported you're less likely to be
cooperative so as a consequence
sanctuary cities provide a framework for
that kind of engagement what they do not
do is sanction people that are here with
violent criminal records or in jail for
felonies to be released there are
however some exceptions and that's where
this tragedy in San Francisco fell and
there are gaps that need to be closed
unquestionably but there's a lot of
Mythology on it well that cleared up a
lot of it and
and I assume some of them are good
people yeah
Caitlin how can universities distance
themselves from the lingering power of
fraternity well that's a great question
because fraternities are kind of like
Donald Trump like in a world where
that's too politically correct people go
to some jackass because o it is a breath
of fresh air from political correctness
right exactly in the universities really
can't distance themselves those kids
have a constitutionally protected right
to the freedom of association they're
allowed to join any club they want right
but you'll certainly find I mean they're
vile hideous horrible language that they
use is really the only expression of
free speech that you'll find on many
campuses and the real problem with
what's going on with this political
correctness is that when you can't talk
about things in the open when you drive
it underground it festers and kids start
to think there's some kind of secret
knowledge to be able to get together
behind the closed doors of a fraternity
sure and use the n-word or you know
speak about horribly misogynist comments
they start to think oh we're really
powerful we know the truth behind our
closed doors so there's a real symbiotic
relationship between the fraternity out
of control fraternities and the
political correctness I think okay
Michael what do you make of the recent
study that says sea levels are rising at
a faster rate than we first anticipated
will we have to evacuate our coastal
cities well there was a recent article
by James Hansen who we talked about
earlier has been extremely prescient in
what he has predicted in the past about
climate change so anytime he says
something you want to listen very
carefully to him he has argued that we
could see as much as six feet of
sea-level rise which you know if you
think you look at hurricane sandy
superstorm sandy just that one foot of
sea level rise that we've had already
meant that there were 25 square miles of
additional flooding along New York City
the New Jersey coast it also meant that
there was something like seven and a
half billion dollars
more damage done by that storm so if
that's what one foot does imagine what
six feet do now what I would do
six feet would mean that you're
basically starting to abandon many of
our coastal cities because of not just
the energy or inland well it depends on
the topography I mean with my lawns I
get more southern southern Florida is
very flat so you know six feet of sea
level rise inundates you know a good
chunk of the southern part of Florida
but seriously how far inland like West
Hollywood probably you'll probably be
okay here but you know again that damage
is damage that reverberates through our
economy through the global economy we
all end up paying for the damages that
climate change does anywhere whether
it's our coastlines or you know here in
California where we are seeing
unprecedented drought and wildfire and
that is a problem for the rest of the
country because this is where we get a
lot of our you know our fruit and Nutter
oh there's a lot of lot of all right
well of course you did doc what will Joe
Biden entering the race if he does
derail Hillary Clinton's campaign well
it won't be good news for it right you
can look at it a number of ways in many
ways it may sharpen the debate may
sharpen her message may create a
diffusion in terms of the targeting
coming from the Republicans because I'll
have to target one number of other
candidates or at least Joe Biden himself
so you can look at it multiple ways I
don't think he'll run but I hope he
doesn't run just because of what
happened to his son I hope he runs
because he thinks he'll make a
difference right be an outstanding
president and so it's it's a tough
choice because he's run twice as you
know 87 and oh and during your - then
you know I mean you probably were aware
I did something about Governor Brown
your boss your MIDI boss defending him
vigorously against the charge of ageism
effectives in Playboy this month they
reprinted a lot of it saying that if he
was 43
instead of 73 the guy who turned around
the biggest state in yet the country in
the eighth largest economy would be
absolutely viable as a presidential
candidate and there is no reason why
somebody his age can't do the job it's
completely relative remember Bobby
Kennedy says I wonder what the world
needs are the qualities of youth not a
time of life but a state of mind a
quality of imagination jerry brown's who
proves that point and i would argue and
put it and i would argue to counter i
think Rubio proves the point the other
degree i don't think his points of view
represent state of mind that it was
progressive as his age right and not the
way package young it's that he's dumb
but you know it's a very important
question because Trump is 69 Hillary is
69 Bernie Sanders is 73 and Joe Biden is
72 or 73 so we have all these people
around this age and none of them seem
like they couldn't do the job how old
was McCain win' McCain was 72 72 72 when
he ran a cane was 72 oh wow how old it
yeah Oh like 300 yeah he did seem oh and
Reagan was 69 when Reagan was 60 not
right yeah well it would be the same
right he came by the way was an example
of a Republican who was extremely good
on climate change at one point well you
know I don't think he's changed his
views I think he's maybe a little
quieter about it now right okay
Gavin do you support the legalization of
recreational marijuana
as as some folks may know we very likely
have a ballot initiative 2016 to tax and
regulate marijuana for adults
if strong confidence will win we got to
do it right and be thoughtful and deal
with the legitimate concerns folks have
about our children and not allowing too
big tobacco to come in become big
marijuana right so we want to do it a
very thoughtful way and we'll have that
opportunity initiative and your for
leading they're leaving the all right I
know you always have been yeah yeah and
that would be good because I mean four
states have it legal now yeah California
which has been on the forefront of so
many things has been lagging on this we
weren't close to being first on gay
marriage you know I'm going to start
calling us west Arizona thing I mean the
thing about it is
marijuana is already legal in California
in the way that we used to have to buy a
beer in Utah right you have to sign up
for the membership club is that right
for you for you a drink
Wow California have to jump through the
hoop you get right direction and you get
it and I think as a country is this
really what we want to spend 50 billion
dollars a year on fueling an enormous
law-enforcement bureaucracy the
militarization of police departments as
they seize you know as they the
rationale for well this is why we need
an armored personnel carrier to enforce
the drug warrant for a nonviolent
marijuana offenders and the civil asset
forfeiture that comes along with it and
for a conservative concerned about the
size and growth of government this is
something you should absolutely be for
yeah because it's one of the most
effective ways of reducing the size and
scope and influence and hypocrisy you've
got right I've said that years ago that
this is an issue the Republicans could
have stolen from the Democrats
absolutely altering and freedom is a
government right always has this it's in
his core yeah yeah well he also has a
giant cash crop of cannabis in Kentucky
we say that twelve times
what do you mean geez I have cash pop of
cannabis do you want to go visit
Kentucky yes it's a cannabis growing
State I'm sorry I probably good soup
well lots of states they grow it but you
mean secretly well I guess since it's
not legal there yet but I can't imagine
other than his being a libertarian
although I agree we seem to know a lot
about this I am I'm saying this as a
mother in addition to what Steve is
saying these kids are going to try it
and I'd rather they it there be some
regulatory oversight of it and stop
wasting money overcrowding our prisons
and creating criminals and such and you
know you make a point and as a parent to
your point without belaboring this and
you guy hey I love this panel I'm
impressed
the two of you have this point of view
but you know drug dealers don't card
they don't care how old you are they
don't care what your selling Asscher die
and so from a parent's perspective I
appreciate that point of view and so
look the thing about California though
one should not underestimate the impact
this will have not only across the
country but around the world notably
with the cartels down in Mexico we
produce just in the Emerald triangle
it's that Mendocino Humboldt Area
California roughly twelve billion
dollars of cannabis at wholesale a year
we know we make the rest of the world
for this this the impact of what we do
will be much more significant certainly
than I would argue Colorado Washington
Oregon and Alaska combined so it's a
very very serious debate for serious
people and I hope we don't demean the
debate by talking about stoners and
tobey's and the usual rhetoric
you know I hate that and to your point
you know the the dispensaries you're
right it makes me feel dishonest and
like a criminal because I genuinely
suffer from whatever it is I told them I
thank you very much ladies
you